such matters must be discussed with a
small council that is what i'm doing
so
what is your advice derotto
otto hightower is from a very old
wealthy powerful household who have been
front
and center
of politics
for
hundreds of years if those shipping
lanes should fall it will beggar our
ports the crown has heard your report
lord corliss and takes it under
advisement
he's the king's hand
so he's very close to the king he's an
adviser to the king he has an eye on
everything i think more than anyone
otto knows what's going on
anywhere in the kingdom at any given
place he has a vast network of spies in
the modern sense his room would have you
know a wall of um
televisions
my darling
he is a father he's constantly
struggling
between his duties and his grieving
interior as a father
why don't you destroy yourself
there's an ambiguity around his um
motivations and intentions it's a tough
job your grace this is the last thing
any of us wish to discuss at this dark
hour but i consider the matter urgent
what matter
that of your succession you know a show
like this is such a big kind of
sprawling metropolis you know by
necessity and we've really kind of
created this little community you know
um that is really supportive and fun
showing up for that each day
that's been a joy i've laughed
so heartily so often
that's never a bad thing